D
SHARE THIS MESSAGE.
THAT'S BEING IN OUR FIRST
GUEST LEO TERREL AND ROB
SMITH.
INVESTOR THOUSAND TIMES TO
COME ON THE SHOW AND THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME BUT HERE YOU
ARE.
AND THERE YOU ARE IN LOS
ANGELES WHAT YOU MAKE OF THIS
WEEK QUICK.
>> FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME ON.
MONOLOGUE WAS ON.
THE UGLINESS OF RACISM IS THE
CONDITION OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
THEY USE IT TO PLAY IDENTITY
POLITICS.
THEY PIT ONE GROUP AFTER
ANOTHER AND THAT'S WHY YOU
HAVE THE GERRYMANDERING GOING
ON IN LOS ANGELES.
BUT IT'S SIMPLE.
THEY GET A PASS.
WHY BECAUSE JAMES KLEINBERG OR
OBAMA THEY GIVE THAT EXCUSE TO
COVER UP THE RACISM.
IT IS ALIVE AND WELL IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THE NUMBER REASON WHY I LEFT
THE PARTIES IS THAT LAST PIECE
BY JOE BIDEN SAID IF YOU DON'T
VOTE FOR ME THEN YOU AIN'T
BLACK.
THEN I WILL TELL YOU RIGHT NOW
HISPANICS AND BLACKS ARE
LEADING THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
JOE BIDEN IS THE IMPERIAL
WIZARD OF THE DEMOCRATIC.
- - PARTY.
STEVE: EVEN SAYING THIS IS
BEEN THE MOTIVATION FOR A
WHILE.
>> LOOK AT THE MEDIA
STANDPOINT.
THIS WAS A REPUBLICAN WITH
THESE REMARKS IT WOULD BE
OUTRAGEOUS OTHERWISE THIS
WOULD BE MAJOR NEWS AND THE
NEWS CYCLE FOR THE ENTIRE WEEK
BUT WE DIDN'T HEAR A WHOLE LOT
ABOUT IT BUT IN TIME THE ONLY
TIME WE READ ABOUT IT IN THESE
OUTLETS DID NOT SHARE THESE
WERE DEMOCRATS THAT MADE THE
STATEMENTS WHICH IS WHY ONE OF
THE REASONS FROM THE DOUGLAS
SOCIETY ENTITY IS TO SHARE
THIS WITH THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN
COMMUNITY THAT MAY BE
CENTER-RIGHT MEANING THAT THEY
WERE SWEPT OVER BY THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
THEY COLLUDE WITH THE DNC AND
DEMOCRATS TO WHITE WASH ALL OF
THE RACISM THAT COMES FROM THE
LEFT AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS I WANT TO DO WITH THE
DOUGLAS SOCIETY IS HIGHLIGHT
THAT.
LET ME MAKE ONE POINT.
TALKING ABOUT PLANNED
PARENTHOOD WHICH IS BASICALLY
MANY DON'T KNOW IT WAS STARTED
BY A WHITE SUSPECT ON -┘-
SUPREMACIST MARGARET SANGER.
THIS IS THE WHITEWASHING THE
DEMOCRATS DO WITH AMERICAN
HISTORY OF WHAT I'M TRYING TO
COMBAT.
STEVE: WHAT IS AMAZING ABOUT
THIS IS THE SHAMELESSNESS.
OBAMA SAYS REPUBLICANS ARE
RACIST AND GAVIN NEWSOM BARELY
WRAPS THEM ON THE KNUCKLES
MADE OFA CONFRONT THEM BIDEN
SHOWED UP TWO OF THEM HAD NOT
RESIGNED.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN SHAMELESS.
>> AND MARTINEZ THE PRESIDENT
OF THE L.A. CITY COUNCIL WHO
MADE THE STATEMENT TWEETED
CALLING TRUMP A RACIST.
THEY WANT TO WHITEWASH EVERY
TRUMP REPUBLICAN BUT THAT'S A
PERSON WHO MADE THE STATEMENT
IT IS SMOKE AND MIRRORS.
I HAVE BEEN A CIVIL RIGHTS
ATTORNEY FOR 30 YEARS AND
TRYING TO FIGHT DISCRIMINATION
IT IS THE HEART AND SOUL THEY
SELECT PEOPLE BASED ON SKIN
COLOR AND RACE.
FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE AN
INCOMPETENT VICE PRESIDENT
SELECTED BECAUSE OF SKIN COLOR
AND RACE A WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY TOTALLY INCOMPETENT
BASED ON SEXUAL ORIENTATION
AND COLOR.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY LOOKS AT
EVERYTHING POLICY AND
REGULATION AND HAS TO STOP AND
THAT'S WHY HISPANIC AND BLACK
PEOPLE OF ALL COLORS LEADING
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY TWO YEARS
AGO I WAS MUCH HAPPIER WHEN I
LEFT THE PARTY.
STEVE: THIS IS THE CULMINATION
OF RACIALIZING EVERYTHING
INCLUDING WHAT THEY WERE DOING.
THAT IS THEIR DEFINING UNIT OF
ANALYSIS.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS YOU HAVE
TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT THAT YOU
HAVE TO KNOW THIS IS THAT
EVERY SINGLE THING IS ABOUT
RACE ABOUT GENDER AND SEXUAL
ORIENTATION IT IS TO SLICE AND
DICE PEOPLE INTO THE SMALLER
GROUPS THAT THEY HAVE YET TO
GIVE US A REAL VISION OF WHAT
THEY REALLY BELIEVE THAT
AMERICAN SOCIETY SHOULD BE
THAT PEOPLE CAN GIVE TO
AMERICA.
WHEN THERE IS A LACK OF THAT
VISION WITH IDENTITY POLITICS
THEY WILL COMPETE IN THE
REASON SO MANY BLACK LATINOS
ARE COMING OVER TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS THEY SEE A
CLEAR VISION FOR WHO THEY ARE
AS AMERICANS REGARDLESS OF
RACE OR GENDER OR SKIN COLOR.
WE ARE AMERICAN WE WILL NOT
SURVIVE AS A COUNTRY UNTIL WE
START THINKING LIKE THAT MORE
AND IDENTITY POLITICS A LITTLE
BIT LESS.
STEVE: WHILE SAID BOTH OF YOU.
THIS IS SO HEARTENING TO SEE
YOU BOTH AND MANY OTHERS
FIGHTING FOR GENUINE EQUALITY
OF OPPORTUNITY REGARDLESS OF
RA